I think you know avid started quarry by
digitizing the filmmaking process taking
film and converting a digital now that
the whole process all the way
consumption is fully digitized avid has
had an advantage because we're anchoring
at the beginning so we've tried to
change with the times as the business
model has changed which is fairly
significant we've changed along with it
as long the way we stayed in the lead
position as a result it's an exciting
night last night oh yea noise this fancy
clothes and everything well so when but
talked about how those movies were made
differently than movies that would have
seen five or ten years ago the business
model first of all Cory has changed
dramatically not only how you create
content today but how you optimize it
how you monetize it has changed
significantly a lot more collaboration
take somebody like the grand budapest
hotel wonderful winners last night you
know wes anderson had to shoot that all
over the world primarily in London
German in here in LA using cloud-based
collaboration for editing for
distribution for marking the content for
rights management really incredible
technical accomplishment that's one
example Birdman I'm here in Mexico City
the day after the Oscars are so happy
for Alejandro here think about the
complexity that movie if hopefully
you've seen it if you don't you'll
notice it looks like it's one take one
continuities film but in fact it was
shot over multiple tracks and they give
the illusion as though or one story and
that's the kind of thing that's
happening with media technology today so
let's let's back up a little bit and
talk about the cloud and talk about sort
of how that process is very different
what's happening right now with the
content as it's being shot we all we
know what a movie set looks like we know
what the director is like shooting that
stuff and and then the stuff comes out
of the can or comes off the camera in a
digital format and then what happens to
the content then yeah well that's the
interesting thing and that's probably
the most significant change in the
actual business model of moviemaking
it's what happens after marking it
tagging at protecting it making it
available through multiple distribution
channels globally easily with multiple
languages etc is how the business model
has changed fairly significantly so the
digitization of the file record coming
off a camera all the way to your
consumption on an eye
pattern iphone on internet or skype
you're up i'm looking at here wherever
you have the rights to the business
model has really changed is causing
media companies to change rethink how
they cut movies how they produce them
also who they hire and the technologies
they deploy so it's a really interesting
time for media because of all these
changes is the pace of finishing a movie
faster because of this because of this
cloud-based technology oh absolutely i
think about you know let's think about
Tom cross who did whiplash for best film
editing last night they wanted to get
that show out for Sundance because it's
a more of an indie esque type film they
actually finished production in one week
later we're able to demonstrate that
film at sundance that simply wasn't
possible before in the traditional model
the fact that it's fully digitized and
you have software like ours it expands
at camera sequence and allows you to
manipulating quickly and do all the rest
of the business components concurrently
is really what movie making is all about
today and it's really exciting you still
know this greater than festivals to
carry the day and I wonder you know in
terms of sort of the map where the
people are who are working in a film
that it changes both how quickly you can
work in other word you work around the
clock but also this notion of what you
pay people whether they're in Los
Angeles or London or in Berlin that you
can maybe find cheaper people than you
have to be stuck with in Hollywood even
though there were new york even though
there may be the best but they're also
the highest paid exactly i mean i would
say that first of all you can optimize
your cost structure through labor
arbitrage but also it's more the savings
on travel so if you can attract the best
anywhere in the world who happen to be
in germany or Mexico or or wherever it
might be the fact that you can work
collaboratively as though you're next to
each other in a common session still
protect the file secure the file and all
the other components that's really the
key and yes there's also potential cost
savings but i think the cost savings
mainly you don't have to fly everybody
around anymore and you don't have to do
as much on in location because the
technology allows you to add so much to
the richness of the story when you look
across all the other companies in
Silicon Valley companies to cover here
in Bloomberg West so much are there
particular innovations that you've been
able to borrow
for your business that are that are
happening with other software companies
other technology companies for example
you know software is a service building
by the seat and so on it's amazing by
the way I love your your location there
I live right down the street there I'm
just never there in San Francisco but we
gotta get you from Mexico you're all the
way not sure you can't come up this tree
next time come up this tree but please
tell us you know when you look at
Silicon Valley where do you see the
innovation you're trying to steal those
great ideas for your company yeah I
think what it is is you know avid was
born and raised in media so what we try
and do is look for the very latest
cutting-edge technologies one of the
reasons I'm there in Silicon Valley
myself and we have major offices in
Silicon Valley as well as we're in 140
different countries around the world but
we have to adopt those in a media-savvy
way security more recently as a good
example as a lot of great security
technologies but we have to adapt it to
the needs of the media industry
specifically and of course after what's
happened with Sony that's front and
center on a lot of our clients you know
strategies today